[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, and welcome
to Dev.Bytes.
My name is Jan-Felix Schmakeit,
and I'm from the
Android Developer
Relations team.
In this episode, we are looking
at the Hierarchy
Viewer and how you can use that
tool to help you optimize
your layouts and views
in your application.
And we are going to be using
the BaconReader sample
application again that you've
seen in one of the other
Dev.Bytes before.
Let's have a look at our
Hierarchy Viewer again,
because I noticed there's
something strange going on in
one of our layouts.
So we have our main article
view, where we have some text,
we have a title, and we have a
background picture, and then
we have our main body of text
here, so it's what's happening
here at the top of
the current view.
And our hierarchy looks very,
very complicated.
We have RelativeLayout and
then we have FrameLayout.
And then we have the ImageView
and then we have
TextView down here.
So we can definitely
simplify that.
And each of these steps in our
layout adds extra time that's
needed to measure and draw
everything to the screen.
So if you go to our layout here,
so this is where we're
defining what the image and
what the title looks like.
So this is very, very
confusing, we have a
RelativeLayout here,
FrameLayout, LinearLayout.
Let's simplify this.
So the way this is structured
is that we have an ImageView
that has our main-- the big
picture that we have in the
background.
And then we have this gradient
on top of that.
And then we have our title.
And then we have a smaller
subtitle as well, a
subheading.
Let's simplify this a lot.
What we can do is we can simply
have the ImageView, the
big picture.
And then we can just use one
simple view on top, we can use
a TextView on top.
In the TextView, we can specify
the background as the
gradient that we have.
We can set the gravity of our
text here to bottom, which
means that the text that we've
put inside the title is drawn
at the bottom of the image.
This is all we have down here,
so we can have a place.
All of this.
The RelativeLayout, you
lay everything out.
The simple FrameLayout, if you
have an ImageView, and you
have a TextView on top.
And the TextView contains
the background
and the entire text.
But you're saying, look, this
title, this headline actually
contains two different
or three different
types of text styles.
We have our main headline,
and then some
smaller text down below.
To do that, we have to use
TextAppearance Spannables.
And we have one simple TextView,
but you can style
different parts of your
TextView differently.
So here we have these
TextAppearanceSpan objects.
And you're loading each of
them in with a different
TextAppearance style that
we have to find in XML.
That's just a normal style.
We're loading this in.
And then when we set up the
views, if we set the title,
this is where we are loading
the text here.
So we are using a
SpannableString to do this.
And a SpannableString allows
you to set a text, and then
you can apply different
spannables
for parts of a text.
So in our case here, the first
thing we do is we compile our
text we want to display,
including the [INAUDIBLE]
characters.
And then we apply each of the
different texts appearances to
a part of this string.
In this case, here we have the
title appearance, we have the
[? by-text ?]
underneath that, and
then we have the
AuthorAppearance as well.
We basically just specify the
start and end characters.
It's a normal character count.
So once we've done that,
we basically set the
SpannableString to our
TextView using the
SpannableBuffer type, so that
it gets applied properly.
We keep our setMovementMethod,
and we can remove our old way
of setting the title.
And if you start our application
again, you will
see that it basically looks
exactly the same, but we have
much, much fewer views than what
we had before, simply by
using TextAppearance spannables
and combining them
together into one
single TextView.
So let's see what it
looks like here.
And as you can see, it looks
basically identical to what we
had before.
But our layout hierarchy
is much, much simpler.
So I really hope you're going
to try HierarchyView in your
own application and see what it
looks like and how you can
optimize your application
to make it
perform much, much better.